The staple ingredient for both corn and tortilla
chips is, of course, corn.
An ear of corn is made up of individual rows
of kernels, and each kernel is attached to
the cob via the tip cap located at the very
bottom of the kernel.
Strip away the tip cap and the hilum is revealed.
The hilum is what seals the base of each kernel
and draws in water and other nutrients needed
during the growth process.
The hilum, in a way, serves as a sort of umbilical
cord for the kernel.
Once the kernels detach from the cob, the
hilum remains as a type of scar from where
it was connected.
corn2The hilum starts out clear then progresses
to light green, then light brown, and finally
black, which shows up on more mature kernels.
It is these mature kernels that are used to
make corn and tortilla chips.
Since these specks of hilum do not disappear
during the cooking process, they remain visible
in the final food product.
In addition to corn and tortilla chips, the
black hilum can also typically be seen on
taco shells, corn tortillas, and other similar
foods made with corn.